I think Frank from Donnie Darko is
likely inspired by ancient folklore from
northern Europe both the looming threat
of Doom in the Shaggy costume and creepy
bunny mask nods to the puka a
shape-shifting animal spirit trickster
monster evidence pukas can take the form
of any animal including human although
they usually retain some animal features
like tail or ears they taunt their
victims with death but do not kill and
commonly appear on Sawan or Halloween
night puka carry their victims on
strange violent and purposeless Journeys
sounds very similar to Frank if you ask
me there's some obvious commonalities
between Frank and Harvey a life-sized
rabbit in a 1950s comedy who actually is
called a puka in the movie and also
happens to be a mischievous and
unnatural looking rabbit only the
protagonist can see so next time you're
gathered to debate the 2001 cult classic
impress your pals Frank is more than a
Shaggy costume and a creepy mask he's
likely got his lucky rabbit's foot
embedded in the folklore of the ancient
puka